وبعدما رجع حتى الان من نتائج هل يمكن
القول ان ترامب خسيره رهانه في هذه
الانتخابات لان كثيرين ممن دعامهم خسروا
السباق الانتخابي قبل اغلاق صناديق
الاقتراع سؤلترامب عن مقدار الفضل الذي
يجب ان يحصل عليه عقب النتائج فقال اعتقد
انه اذا فازوا يجب ان احصل على كل الفضل
اما اذا خسروا فلا ينبغي ان انام على
الاطلاق وفق هذا المنطق تحدث الرئيس
الخامس والاربعون للولايات المتحده لكن
اسماء في الحزب الجمهوري بدات الترم
السهام باتجاه ترامب محمله اياه مسؤوليه
الفشل في حدوث المد الاحمر في الوقت نفسه
كان الفائز الاكبر هذا الشخص جون ديسانتس
المنافس الرئيس لترامب في ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري عام 20 و24 فازه ديسمبر 20 نقطه
وجعل فلوريدا اكبر ولايه متارجحه في
امريكا سابقا معقلا للجمهوريين
في خطاب النصر الذي القاه
وضعت المحن قويا فيه بانه سيواجه ترامب في
20 24 حتى ان بعضا من المحللين اباته
يرجحون ان انتخابات 20 24 ستكونوا تنافسا
بين بيضا وديسمتس
ليت بابا
لكن من ما لا شك فيه ان منكري الانتخابات
الرئاسيه 2020 من الجمهوريين بالطبع حقق
انتصارات جيده لكنهم يعانون ايضا من
انتكاسات كبيره خصوصا مع اعراب الناخبين
عن ثقه اكبر في ان الانتخابات في ولايتهم
جرت بشكل عادل ودقيق فقال حاول ثمانيه من
كل عشره ناخبين انهم موافقون جدا او الى
حد ما من ان الانتخابات في ولايتهم ستكون
عادله ودقيقه في المقابل لعيبه انتخابات
الثلاثاء دورا في تزايد قلق الامريكيين
بشان الديمقراطيه في بلادهم قال ما يقرب
من سبعه من كل 10 ناخبين ان الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه مهدده جدا او الى حد ما وفقا
لاستطلاعات الراي المبكر الذي باشرته شركه